carrying on from the
the first film
what's the point in doing a martial art
we call Aikido martial arts a lot of
other martial artists out there MMA
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
perhaps a lot of other martial arts
don't think that Aikido is a martial
arts
because perhaps what they're saying is
very
what we say
Dynamic but they can see that the
bouquet is kindness out beautifully with
nagay and when the throw
not a great deal of power can be seen
even though those training you like you
don't know that there's a lot of power
in Aikido that's not seen if done
correctly because it's about timing
angles
but if we're we'll go back to being it
called a martial arts
then what are the spin-offs from doing
this Aikido
in the first part of the film I talked
about techniques and I talked about
putting them in different categories
well one of the categories I want I'm
wanting to talk about here is
us us as The Human Side us as the human
being what do we get from doing Aikido
let's take the segment of
I hope that it's made me a martial
artist
well I'm a human being when I started
and my teacher starts to shout at me
correct me and my techniques get better
over the years
and I keep improving and I'm happy that
I find another master
you see for the first 10 years of my
Aikido I became the first and then
second and
then I met Saito sensei in New Zealand
and even though it was a second Dan
the first cues the brown belts that
trained under him they were go from New
Zealand to Irma spend time there
and
he went there because he was asked to do
a seminar I can't remember how long it
was it was a four or five day when it
was a nice long one
and I flew out there and met them
and I was second down feeling really
good in the UK I'd put myself as one of
the best at the time because I was
training
a minimum three times a week every
single day I would train the weapons
minimum half an hour
the morning before I go to bed I train
again so
seven days a week I was putting in my
training so I considered myself a
devotee student of the art
I used to train in the top place in
London every once or twice a week is
extra to my two classes in Cambridge so
I was a good boy I'd done all the right
things went to the right places a bit
like going to the best schools if you
like at your University
so I wasn't doing anything wrong and I
was being taught by what I considered
and everyone else at that time
considered the best teachers
so I go to New Zealand and I arrive
there and I'm standing around waiting
for class to start and I'd always get
there early and that was these two brown
belts and they were doing the 31 Kumi
Joe
part practice
hello Watson I couldn't believe
how good they were I knew the Carter but
I didn't know there was another side to
it
the anti-carter I knew the 13 Joe Carter
but I didn't know there was a part of
the practice
now
when I I'm looking I'm thinking back
then I remember they were on the grass
just just trailing away
and
it made me sort of go from this really
positive person that traveled across the
world thinking that my Aikido was one of
the top in the UK for my level you know
there was higher grades but I'm talking
about at second down level and I'd
recently got my second down
so it was a new second now
but there was these two first cues
during the 31 community
way way better than me I mean it was
ridiculous it was like
you know me being a third queue compared
with them being a first kid
so I realized the first 10 years of my
Aikido life
was having fun thinking I was doing a
martial art
for what I was doing I was doing
cardiovascular training
and I was um
I don't think I was actually aware of
anything other than my own trading and
myself
just having a good time really didn't
think about the martial art aspect of
what
should a martial arts EST get from doing
all this icono
so over the years I I realized that
unbelow to me I was observing I was
observing people in the streets just
normal people if they had an unusual
walk or if they were more astute than
other people walking in the street
so you just pick up these things and you
don't know why you're looking at them
it's not a case of being nosy it's just
a case of you spot these things you you
see something and you you just analyze
it in a
in a millisecond then you've analyzed it
and over the years I've been trying to
find out more about how my mind works
and how if you get mind control
and it's like my head has become like a
cake and divided into all these
different segments
of what I think we get for my kiddo
so talking about
what we observe
is because I believe from the weapons
that you have to switch
switch on you become attuned and once
you become attuned that switch
eventually will stay in the on position
so I'd like to just give you a small
thing here
we do it automatically and we don't know
that we're doing it so you don't have to
be psychic you don't have to be anybody
special you just have to be a human
being
that knows that they've got a natural
gift a natural ability
that has been with you all the time but
the better you get of something the more
you can enhance it
so let's just put you in a position that
you might decide to look at a tennis
match a professional tennis match
sometime like I'm watching at the moment
please do so if you don't know what I'm
talking about so that it makes sense to
you
the person who's about to serve
there's a ball boy ball all girl
standing with some balls in the hand
the professional turns to them they
throw them three perhaps four balls
they
sometimes you'll notice the professional
will look at the balls in the hand and
they throw one down perhaps two down
they perhaps throw one down they ask for
another one to be thrown they'll look at
them they'll throw another one down
this works every single time if you
watch a professional match
now
I never thought of it before until
yesterday
but
how do they know I mean these balls have
changed every few
uh sets or matches I don't know enough
about tennis to be correct but after
they've played several uh games
they you hear new balls please
so the balls aren't worn out are they
they're they're regularly changed and if
you can tell a good ball from a bad Bowl
um
then you'd think they must see something
on the ball
and that's what gives them the
indication
so I just thought that it was uh viewing
like looking at Apples knowing whether
it's a good apple or bad apple in a
millisecond
but then I was watching um a little bit
deeper because it's suddenly made me
realize why do they bother to even all
the balls are new why bother to select
them why don't they just take two balls
one to point in their pocket one to
serve with and then get two balls next
time why do they go through three or
four throw two away go back to two
so I I've always thought for years that
they obviously see something on the ball
a scarf or something like apple and they
throw it away
so here's the point of both of the films
that I've made
I realized that
if I look a little bit closer they often
take the balls and they throw one away
without looking at them
so how do they know
what ball to throw away
and I believe that's because our
intuition
the more years we do Aikido and the more
years we do any martial art or sport or
anything where we're perfecting the art
we're also perfecting the mind
and sometimes we don't put enough into
them giving the Mind time and we give
too much to doing the technical
but the mind is a thing that
as I said
they might the tennis player may be
winning winning they get over the six
games they're even the other person's
got six they've got six
then also the tie break comes
the younger more inexperienced in years
not always
but mainly what I've watched
loses the tie break
because they just they can't hit the
accurate shots because they'd so
desperately want to win and that makes
them so their quality
um files them
and the mature person
is still under pressure but they've been
there before they've they've been to the
panic and Beyond they've been beyond
panic
they've come close to
the finalization of losing so many times
that it becomes weak weak and weaker so
that they can help still have more
accurate
um shots or with reactions than the
person who hasn't had so long
so I hope you find found this of
interest and to
um I encourage you to search your mind
view others it doesn't matter what
whether they're in the street or whether
it's Sports just just view the person
watch a football player or watch
something that you enjoy and and try to
get inside that person's
by you
reaching out your mind to them and see
what conclusions you come up with
and then in turn it may help you
conclude your own mind to know how to
act while under pressure
so I hope you found this of interest
thank you for listening and watching